Probably
the,
uh,
most important
way of
resolving issues.
Is it face to face confrontation is a
personal,
uh,
interaction.
And far too often things are left to
other sort of
others to try to solve what the
principles should be solving these
issues by direct,
uh,
interaction.
Uh,
surely it,
we're doing lots of things,
right?
Uh,
you know,
one of the problems is,
uh,
you know,
we,
we dwell on the things that aren't
right,
because those are the things we want to
change.
Those are the things we want to correct.
Uh,
but it's an awful lot that's being done
right.
And I think in the last seven years,
uh,
in New York City,
as a whole different attitude about
living in the city,
about working in the city,
about how you interact with people that
you don't know.
Uh,
and that has to do with just a change of
how things are done.
Uh,
both the,
uh,
from the public perspective as well as
from a private perspective.
Uh,
as an architect,
I can't say there's been a great deal of
good architecture,
uh,
that's,
a resident in this city.
But there's a different attitude about
architecture in this city than ever
existed before.
It has to do with a feeling this is our
place,
that you'd be great.
And I think there's that never existed
before.
So how do we cope now?
We're beyond that.
Yeah.